Có gái nhẹ team filler môi, chia hơn 1.5mm đối bí để làm đẹp.
Vìen, 2.5 tụi, đã chia hơn 1.5mm đối bí để phẫu thuật tầm vi,
tiêm phí lờ 1 tháng với mong ước có về ngoài nữ tính cực độ, bất chức việc không thể khai miệp.
Vìen bắt đầu tiêm phí lờ từ năm 2013, khi có vừa đủ tuổi làm phẫu thuật tầm vi hợp pháp,
tôi luôn muốn trong tận lữ tính đến bắt đầu bởi môi của nói.
Cứ mỗi hai đền bụng tần, Vìen lại bây tụi bán nhà xác đức để tiêm môi,
môi chuyển tị tốn hơn 2.5 đối bí, nhiều bệ câu, sớt đẹp là không có giá.
Có cố chứ xảy rằng đối môi càng lớn thì cô càng cảm thấy hấp dẫn và giống chính mình hơn.
Pênh nhìn, ngoài hình của cô về nhiều tránh khai.
Có người uống hộ, nhưng cô không ít ý kiến chế dễu hỏi môi cô là việc hoặc quả bóng sư li côn,
thậm chí chỉ chích mắt sĩ đã không tử bánh.
Vìen đáp trả, tôi nghĩ họ về anh tị thôi, người hành quốc thực sự sẽ không để lại bị lận tuổi.
Cái tại, môi của Vien đã lời đến nước hiện cô họ ăn uống và không thể phép miệng hoàn toàn.
Vì, cô vẫn chưa thấy đủ và sẽ tiếp tục làm đen.
Có chiếc sẹt, tôi đang tạo ra phía bản của nước trong mơ.
Tôi không cần ai hiệu hãy chất nhận.
Các chuyên gia chơi rằng Vien có thể có giống hiệu của bệnh nghiệp tâm Mỹ với đặc điểm luôn không hay lòng với vệ ngoài,
dễ dẫn đến chế và chừng cảm hiểu không kiểm soát.